hey guys it's justine and today i am so
excited because i'm unboxing something
very very special now i'm a huge huge
fan of tracking data about myself my
sleep my activities even my food intake
and now there's something that we can
use to track our pet's health today
we're going to be unboxing the whistle
health pet tracker and this is great
because not only can you use it for your
dog but you can also use it for your cat
it'll track things like licking it
tracks water intake and it kind of just
gives you an overall picture of what
your pet is doing without further ado
let's unbox this and check out he loves
wearing a collar more than anything and
we usually only use harnesses on him so
when we put a collar on him he gets so
excited
ah here it is look at this we need to
charge the device install the app and
follow in app instructions i can do that
so here it is this says charge me we
have a cable that comes with it quick
start guide oh my goodness for humans my
dog can read whatever round it okay all
right okay so let's get this all set up
so this is the whistle health okay we
need to plug it into pair plug in we see
the light so pair the device get to know
our pet maddie okay maddie is a dog he
is a male
yes he is
he is a
bish pooh i think yeah he's probably
like 16 pounds i think add a photo of
maddie yeah please okay this is not his
best photo but it's the last one that i
took oh you want to get to know me okay
yes we want notifications activating
maddie's whistle health set activity
goals help maddie stay on track there it
is okay let's get this all charged up
and then i'm gonna go put it on maddie
okay so i just told maddie that i have
something for him and he's losing his
mind look at this maddie this is your
whistle health tracker okay so we gotta
get this all
looped up on your collar are you ready
to wear this
all right
oh he loves wearing a collar more than
anything
don't you buddy
don't you look how handsome you look
you're so beautiful you know beautiful
boys you are you're an angel you were
just looking your butt so i'm not gonna
let you lick my face
yeah i hope you understand
okay would you like to go for a walk
[Music]
so this is day one of maddie's seven-day
journey to gather all of his health
insights so the first seven days is
really important to kind of get their
daily habits so after that we'll
continue tracking but here we go day one
is underway okay maddie come on where'd
it go this way let's go
hmm well the one thing that the whistle
tracker has not done is uh
made him listen
anymore that's probably my fault but
we're working on it
come on buddy
do you want to go get a treat let's go
get a treat
matty we can't go that way we have to go
this way
[Music]
so we are back from our seven day
whistle kind of baseline testing and
i love this thing so much it was amazing
because the first full day that he
actually wore it i took a little road
trip to san diego and i walked around so
much i think that first day we walked
like seven or eight miles and i was of
course tracking stuff on my watch but it
was really wild to just see the data on
maddie's little whistle app and it's
great because i can actually go in here
and i can see all of his activity that
he's done so here was his saturday on 5
21 we walked 7.7
miles and he also rested for 11.3 hours
so you know he had some resting time he
burned
661 calories i love that this gives you
kind of like a timeline of the day
maddie was walking maddie was active
maddie was running then we have maddie
was resting and then down here at the
end it says low intensity activity for
27 minutes my favorite part about this
though is i can share maddy's day so i
can
change the backgrounds i can
have it be his photo or choose one from
the library so after you have your
little image you can take this and then
share with your friends your family or
even on social media i love this because
my sister and i both share maddie
together so she's been out of town so
this for me has been proof that i have
been doing my parenting duties of making
sure that he takes his consistent walks
so you can go through each day and see
how he did and of course some days were
a little better than others but we have
met all of his goals for the past seven
days okay so you see that he's
scratching i
actually got a little bit sad when i saw
his health data because i have been
seeing him scratch and lick a lot he has
been licking so much he has really bad
allergies it usually gets bad sort of
around like the summer time when there's
like a lot of fleas and stuff like that
i've noticed him licking and i am very
sad because when i clicked in here to
see the health this kind of confirmed
that yes his licking is a problem this
has his looking as rated as severe and
this is like heartbreaking because i
obviously am not around him 24 7 so i
don't know what he's doing when i'm not
watching him and when he is around me i
usually tell him hey stop licking don't
do that and he'll stop but if i'm not
around but this is giving you the data
right here like i can actually see when
the days are the worst so like on the 24
it was really really bad and up here at
the top it has a little action item it
says there's a high chance maddie's skin
is irritated monitor and consult a
professional if the condition does not
improve i also like that i have this
hard proof and the actual data because
sometimes when you go to the vet and you
say yeah he's been licking and you don't
actually have the proof like i can show
them so you can see under the health
data it gives you the scratching licking
sleeping eating and their drinking this
says that his drinking is below average
his eating is average sleeping he is of
course very restful but the scratching
and licking are both elevated and this
shows you how they rank each thing so if
it's infrequent it's 0 to 52 seconds of
daily scratching and he is elevated so
it's 120 to 299 seconds of daily
scratching the battery is currently at
63 and it wasn't entirely 100 a week ago
so the battery life on this thing seems
to be really really good which is great
because i feel like if you are going to
be wearing this health tracker you kind
of want to track as much as possible i
have been taking his collar off every
other night so he does get a little
break in between they do recommend that
you wear at least half of the day so
that you're able to get as much data as
possible and as someone who likes to
collect data i definitely want to be
able to get the most out of it i'm super
grateful that i got a chance to review
this and especially now just being able
to see this data and know that i
definitely need to get him to a vet as
soon as possible to try to get this
little condition taken care of i feel so
bad my little baby's just licking so
much oh does somebody want this treat
that i have come here
come here sit down
that's a good boy
maddie i feel so bad about your licking
but you're such a good dog
sit on mommy's lap
that's not what i told you to do but
that's okay
you're such a good wait and this little
whistle looks so
fancy on you it looks so nice do you
remember our trip when we went to san
diego and you were a good dog you walked
so much he walked so much oh you just
took the treat you took the treat do you
want to see your health data so maddie
here's all your achievements and stats
you can collect badges seven day goal
met you've traveled 25 miles and you've
had the whistle on for seven days
average daily activity is 120 minutes
average daily distance 4.1 miles i love
that it gives you all of this data look
at that you see that well thank you guys
so much for watching i hope you guys
enjoyed this video i have been really
wanting to try this out for a long time
so i'm so excited that i got a chance to
again a huge thank you to whissel for
partnering with me on this video and
actually bringing to my attention that i
need to
get my dog some help and i will keep you
guys posted on his progress and i love
the fact that i can actually see the
progress happening before my eyes not
only will be able to see the changes in
my dog and his behaviors but i can
actually see the data here in the app
you guys want to get more information
about the whistle health tracker i'll
put a link in the description and i
would love to hear from you guys have
you tried these out and i would love to
hear your stories thank you so much for
watching bye
[Music]